hi my name is lindsey paschall
and i'm on cornell cooperative
extension's harvest new york team i will
be discussing the supply chain for
industrial hemp
in new york state with discussions about
state of processors a little bit about
retailers and consumers
in may 2020 a survey was sent out to the
hemp processors
in new york state to find out what the
state of hemp
processing happened in 2019 out of a
little over a hundred
processors in new york state only 24
responded
13 said that they did process hemp in
new york state
and 11 said that they did not
we asked how much hemp did you process
in 2019
11 respondents did not process any hemp
and then the hemp range between zero
and twenty eight thousand two hundred
and seventy eight pounds
with a total of hundred twenty two
thousand and eighty eight pounds
processed in your state according to the
respondents
in 2019 we asked what the minimum
cbd content that hemp process required
from their growers it ranged anywhere
from 0 to 12 percent
of cbd percentage they would like from
growers
then we asked processors what they were
processing hemp into
this included hemp oil seed cake
biofuel plastic raw materials hemp fiber
pellets and that was for pellet stoves
extracts such as powders base oil
protein tinctures flour and cbd
in 2020
we wanted to know what processors were
looking at for their capacity
for processing hemp and you know the
range is
kind of all of the board but included um
weekly basis of 200 pounds um some
processors said
for a month they could only do about two
acres
or anywhere between a thousand and 140
000 pounds with also some processors
responding that they could
do anywhere from six thousand to a
million pounds
within the year
there's not a lot of information out
there in new york state about the state
of
retailers and consumers this will
probably be
potentially a future survey for to find
out from
retailers consumers where the industry
is
there's a lot of predictions on line
about how
retail stores might end up closing
because of cobit 19
you know a lot of people can buy cbd
locally
or they can buy it online so the retail
side is very unpredictable
and so is on the consumer side there's
large predictions that
cbd consumption will continue to
increase between 2020 and 2024
if you have any other questions about
hemp processors in your state
please feel free to reach out to me my
email address
is lep67 cornell.edu